[Música]
[Aplausos]
nunca vi una cosa así
una idea tan simple muy bien explicada a
cambiar algo hay que cambiar o no va a
quedar nada todo va a seguir igual sigo
no quiere
es que sigue igual
hablar probemos con hablar
digo lo mío pero te escucho hablar
y escuchar a hablar
escuchar hablar escuchar hablar escuchar
no de forma tribal
hey
la cosa es tan complicada
respuesta y no podés usar la mirar el
dolor de los otros te ayuda a ver en
perspectiva el propio derecho forma
madre
los hechos que no decidan por vos hay
que moverse usar la palabra
participación acción reacción
katy
y poder
a luchar
[Música]
un punto
y lo voy a usar
para cortar un poco de tela
hacerlo en conjunto el idealismo
en lo profundo de los que
[Música]
pero siempre hay que operar
esa idea
para documentar lo podemos firmar
que tenga entrevistas yo me puedo quejar
si lo crees
por suerte contamos
[Música]
sí
que van a desobedecer
[Música]
nuria y amor
falta una y los pobres juntando la
empanada
está sobre los bandos
en las islas de los millonarios
no perdamos tiempo de caricias
[Música]
tampoco tiempo
y todos
[Música]
a costa de las mujeres
y eso hay que cambiarlo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en un nuevo y hacerlo junto a alguien
que se pare
si a vos
por suerte contamos con los que nos
siguen que van a de eso
con furia y amor
[Música]
estudiar los psicodélicos y entenderlos
y
quiero ver si pueden tirarle una onda
a la salud
[Música]
y quiero que esta acción es tu satélite
gen y asteroide
estar seguro de que vos también
qué
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]